Sandoval sends Ariana like this
page-long text of the first basically
apologizing and she literally looks at
her phone and hands it to me and she
goes I don't even want to read it
Kristen Doty spilling all about the post
scandaval aftermath he just doesn't
like pay attention to responsibility and
he never has during an appearance on the
vile files the reality star shared Tom
Sandoval's alleged texts to Ariana
Maddox after news broke of his
months-long affair with Raquel Levis he
was just gaslighting her there was no
genuine apology he was saying how she
never supports him she doesn't validate
him this is after after she found out
and she was he was blaming why it was
her fault exactly according to Kristin
Sandoval's not so apology had Arianna
questioning their entire relationship
where she started crying and she's like
holding up her phone going so my
relationship he's saying our our
relationship was that like convenience
and contentment or something not love
and romance he said she said Tom said
this about she and Tom and Kristen says
as more details emerged the texts
allegedly became more heated we're like
composing this text in the most mature
way that we can and not leading with
emotions right like letting cooler heads
prevail and just saying listen dude you
gotta at least give her a couple hours
heads up when you need to come home to
pick things up you need to let this rest
for at least a few weeks allow her to
grieve allow her to heal and of course
his response is it's my house I
own half of it I will come and go as I
please and if she has a problem with it
she can leave news of the affair made
headlines just two weeks ago and in the
days following Sandoval issued a
statement on Instagram saying his
biggest regret was dishonoring Ariana
and this year I kind of did a deep dive
and really opened myself up and
experienced new things being single
um and just kind of like living it up
Raquel also came clean in an exclusive
statement to eat tea I want to apologize
for my actions and my choices foremost
to Ariana there is no excuse I I am not
a victim and I must own my actions and I
deeply regret hurting Ariana and while
she doesn't expect sympathy
understanding or forgiveness Raquel is
working to become a better person moving
forward at the time A source told E.T
Raquel trying to reach out to Ariana
before she spoke out publicly Ariana
responded to Raquel but wasn't ready to
receive the apology I am my own person
and I have very strong opinions of my
own as for whether the two have spoken
since
no not at all Ariana doesn't like they I
think uh the network had asked
production at one point in the last few
weeks if Ariana would film with her and
I know production really had her back
and just said we're not even going to
ask her that it's not happening yeah
um they'll have like at the reunion
she'll have to see her that's going to
be bad enough
but no they definitely haven't spoken or
seen each other and Ariana wants nothing
to do with her right now
foreign
[Music]